i want to begin the program today
by engaging in a fact check
of congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez
democrat
socialist from new york i don't spend a
lot of time on this program responding
to all of her various rants and
pronouncements because it would take up
all of our time
and she is one of these members who
thrives on controversy and attention but
because what she's saying on this
particular subject is being fairly
widely repeated on the left including by
some in the media at least elements of
it
i think it is worth
going through the facts
because this is something that's going
to come up i predict for years to come
hopefully decades to come and you'll see
why i say hopefully in a moment
yesterday we had shannon bream on this
show
analyzing what happened at the supreme
court oral arguments in the dobbs case
regarding a mississippi abortion law
that seems likely to be upheld as
constitutional by the justices maybe six
of them
if you read those tea leaves correctly
what else they might do how else they
might restrict or
pair back roe vs wade we don't know yet
we'll find out
probably in late june
and just as a quick aside on the
mississippi law which would bar most
abortions after 15 weeks of pregnancy
that is and it bears mentioning
a very mainstream law if you look at the
world
right our friends on the left often want
to point to europe
as models for government and policy and
other things and they're so enlightened
over there
often i think they're wrong
but by their own standard they should
look at abortion laws throughout almost
all of europe
our abortion laws in this country
are
some of the most inhumane in the world
we're up there with china and north
korea and russia
most countries
have
somewhat significant restrictions on
abortion
if you look across the globe
a large majority of nations restrict
abortions after the first trimester so
12 weeks
this mississippi law is 15 weeks
so in many ways it is right smack in the
middle of the mainstream globally if
that's the type of thing that matters to
you i know that sometimes on the left
they just totally ignore the
international community when it suits
them this is one of those cases
we are a global outlier in a bad way and
yet
even reasonable restrictions on abortion
later in pregnancy are
consistently attacked and assailed by
the hard left the democrats and the
media the media is as biased on this
issue as any issue
out there
as being some sort of attack on women
extreme it's not extreme at all
polling also shows that the overwhelming
majority of americans the overwhelming
majority of american women
support significant restrictions on
abortion particularly in the second and
third trimesters which is what this
would entail in mississippi
i just want to say that at the onset
but what aoc had to say
was one of the many things that we're
seeing from the left and in the media
going after not the legal arguments
being put forward
not citing constitutional
precedent
or constitutional text to justify their
preferred position
which i think is telling what we're
instead seeing
are a number of preemptive attacks on
the very legitimacy of the supreme court
if
they render a decision
that the hard left on abortion does not
like
and they've made these types of threats
before
so rather than arguing on substance
they're saying
what they might do is illegitimate and
would undermine the legitimacy of the
institution
same crowd that runs around with their
hair on fire about norms and
institutions under trump right sometimes
justified sometimes not but they were
guardians of our norms and institutions
but when those same norms and
institutions produce outcomes that they
don't like
because they've lost fair and square
they attack the institutions and try to
change them this is another consistent
pattern that we've seen
from many on the
not even that hard left
it's sort of becoming more mainstream
one of the ways that they're doing this
on the the legitimacy front
is to go after brett kavanaugh that
justice in particular he made if you go
back and read the transcripts
of yesterday's oral arguments i did some
of it this morning
he made some extremely compelling
arguments not just logical but
constitutional arguments alito had some
great questioning as well
but kavanaugh was i think sharp
and powerful i don't know what he's
gonna end up voting or how far he's
willing to go
we'll discover that soon enough but the
way that he was framing his questions
seemed to be setting up a pretty robust
explanation for the way that he might
vote
and so the attacks are coming in
aoc tweeted this
earlier
reminder that brett kavanaugh still
remains credibly accused of sexual
assault on mob multiple accounts
with corroborated details and this year
the fbi admitted it never fully
investigated
yet the court is letting him decide on
whether to legalize forced birth in the
u.s no recusal
let's set aside this term forced birth
separate discussion most americans
support
some restrictions on abortion especially
as i mentioned later in the pregnancy
would that be forced birth that's a very
loaded term
i know of nobody who's remotely serious
who would suggest that brett kavanaugh
because someone accused him of something
in the past with no proof by the way
would have to recuse himself from this
or any case
but apparently aoc
well-known law professor
believes that he ought to
but let's focus on this
her
so-called reminder that justice
kavanaugh she calls him brett
kavanaugh's justice to you madam
still remains credibly accused she says
of sexual assault on multiple accounts
with corroborated details and the fbi
never fully investigated all right one
by one let's take those apart
he was never credibly accused by anyone
the credibility of allegations
must be determined by the proof and
evidence supporting those allegations
there were four allegations against
kavanaugh
three of them are completely discredited
right one of them a girl at yale told
her classmates to this day she's not
really sure it was him she was calling
around trying to crowdsource a memory
decades later with the help of some
left-wing lawyers not credible at all
according to her
and her own actions two of the other
ones have been affirmatively debunked
the crazy gang rape thing with avenatti
remember that one
and then another person
who came forward on behalf of a another
woman and that woman said no she's
describing me that never happened
this is a lie
so let's
dispatch those three examples the one
accusation that got the most attention
was dr
christine blasey ford we had that whole
battle as you might recall in 2018.
was she credible
many people believe that she was they
watched the testimony they watched his
testimony people had various opinions
the key is
for an allegation to be credible
with corroborated details which is what
aoc says you actually have to have
evidence and corroboration there was no
contemporaneous evidence whatsoever that
this happened in fact there was no
evidence that brett kavanaugh and
blasey ford ever even met
let alone something like this happening
what she claimed happened with her story
being extremely inconsistent
there is zero corroboration none
because it was a huge firestorm you
might recall the fbi actually did
revisit this case they had done a bunch
of background checks on kavanaugh he'd
worked in the executive branch and the
judicial branch they'd done it for years
but because of the outcry the fbi looked
into it
they talked to the alleged witnesses who
were supposedly at this party that she
remembers none of them backed her up
none of them
and her one star witness her friend
leland kaiser
was actually the subject of something
that the fbi found out a new piece of
information in this investigation that
they did prior to the confirmation they
found out and leland kaiser the friend
of blasey ford
key witness according to ford's team
she told the fbi that she had been
pressured this is witness tampering
pressured to change her story in order
to hurt kavanaugh and his chances for
confirmation that's what she said
and when it was all over
she went on the record in a book written
by some new york times reporters leland
kaiser the friend and star witness for
blasey ford saying she does not believe
her friend that this happened blasey
ford's own father does not believe it
the career sex crime sex crimes
prosecutor that the republicans brought
in to ask questions of blasey ford she
laid out in detail
multiple inconsistencies in the story to
the point that she said she couldn't
even get a warrant based on this story
it was that filled with holes
the key to me is
no corroboration no evidence the person
that was the closest to offering
corroboration or evidence this friend
ultimately said they were trying to get
me to lie
they pressured me to lie
and by the way i don't believe
christine blasey ford i don't believe
her story
that is what happened
those are the facts
but here's aoc saying oh here's
kavanaugh credibly accused with
corroboration of all this sexual assault
and what i really want you to know about
this is that this was the plan all along
don't take my word for it
listen to the words of debra katz
who was a lawyer for dr ford after the
case she spoke at some conference
and she admitted that a part of this
whole plan of coming forward from dr
ford
was for the purpose
of sullying the reputation of brett
kavanaugh in a way that could hurt him
and hurt his credibility on abortion
related cases
this is part of the reason they did all
of it back in 2018
they admitted it this is cut 22 debra
katz aftermath of these hearings i
believe that christine's testimony
brought about more good than the harm
misogynist republicans caused by
allowing kavanaugh on the court he will
always have an asterisk next to his name
when he takes the scalpel to roe v wade
we will know who he is we know his
character and we know what motivates him
and that is important
it is important that we know and that
was part of what motivated christine
is part of what motivated christine an
asterisk
on abortion jurisprudence this was the
game plan
accuse him there's no evidence
no corroboration accuse him of this make
a huge deal and if he gets on the court
there's an asterisk when it comes to
abortion
and what you need is
demagogic unscrupulous people willing to
ignore all the evidence and make this
allegation and amplify it and aoc
stepped right up to the plate
unsurprisingly because she fits the bill
it doesn't change the facts
that's what happened
now aoc made another argument
as did a reporter
journalist so-called at the washington
post that i will address next let's
quickly break
we'll be right back because i want to
finish this thought on the guy benson
show